all right next caller from the 6-8 to
area code go ahead
hey David this is Colby and Austin again
go ahead Colby well I was gonna ask you
last week you mentioned that you were
you know not a big fan of the abolish
eyes or the lesser-known melt ice
movement because you thought it was like
not pragmatic could you go into it a
little bit more well yeah you know yeah
we actually did address this earlier on
today's show so you'll see the clip
without but basically here's my thing
right now we're dealing with the
midterms
you're not going to abolish ice while
Trump is president unless something
insanely unlikely happened meaning that
for all intents and purposes between
2018 and 2020 or between 2019 and 2021
as the term will be you're not going to
abolish ice and I think that it may be
perceived as an extreme position I do
think that reform repeal and replace ice
something like that is perfectly
reasonable fix ice I don't know I think
that there's from a pragmatic standpoint
more to be gained by focusing on other
platform areas for the midterm elections
and then yeah I'm not against the
abolishment of ice I'm just saying I
think pragmatically it might not be the
best strategy for the midterms yeah I
think I share the same like instinct is
you that people might view that as a
little bit extreme I guess from like for
me personally I've just gotten behind
more of the idea of asking for the full
loaf like whatever you want you ask for
that and you deal with the pragmatism
once you uh you know are debating the
policy or the build it on the table it's
not a Kassie position because I mean
remember had President Obama been
stronger about a serious public option
or even something to the left
he might have ended up further to the
left in his negotiation for what
Obamacare ultimately was so your view is
not invalid I'm applying it just hyper
specifically to ice for the 2018
election right all right all right thank
you appreciate the call thanks to
everybody who called we will take a
quick break and be back right after this